[Music]
hey conan o'brien here with another
edition of clueless gamer this is where
i rate video games uh very ironic
because i don't really play them i'm not
good at them and i kind of hate them
but who better review them than i today
we are tackling one of the biggies halo
4. i have a little bit of a personal
interest in this because i recorded a
voice for halo 4. i'm a character i
don't know where i don't know how i
appear but obviously that's going to be
the highlight of the game let's bring in
my partner here this is aaron blair
aaron you work in which department uh
team coco digital team coco digital okay
uh we're gonna switch you out of there
soon i'd like you parking cars tell me
about
halo 4 what do i need to know to play
this game it's the beginning of a second
trilogy uh in the halo universe
basically there's this uh alien race
called the covenant who was at war with
humanity who is actually having a civil
war with itself between the inner and
outer colonies and the covenant their
theocratic race quick question yes do
you have a girlfriend
continue and they worship
an ancient alien race called the
forerunners who uh perished in battle
with another alien race called the flood
who basically consume all flesh within
the galaxy so why do you know all of
this
i've been playing the halo it's that's
what the game is about you said a
theocratic society yeah do you even know
what that is it's i think it's a
religious they're based around religion
wrong okay it's a society built around
the character of theo from the cosby
stuff so just knowing the fact
anyway continue with your lecture
professor the didact uh he created this
thing called the poser which turns
he turned it against humanity and but
then he
screwed up humanity so then
there's these ai warriors they're made
of computer stuff basically guys are
shooting you you just try to kill them
you just shoot this killer
you could have done that over 40 minutes
ago
now we're gonna watch a quick prologue
oh of course
this never used to happen when i was
coming along in the 80s there was no
prologue to pong do you know what i mean
they didn't tell you the story of the
little blip
it just happened
okay now this is us at the the back end
of the ship we're in cryogenic slumber
we're just floating out in space and i'm
asleep you're asleep
projectile
wow
what an action-packed tail
wait a minute something's happening
who is that that's your uh artificial
intelligence companion cortana
seems like old times she lives on a
microchip that you put in your helmet
can she go anywhere on my body or does
she just have to stay in the home
is she ever
i don't drift south you know
she updated your firmware while you were
asleep
i bet she did
ready to get back to work
i thought you'd never ask
where'd you go
you put her in your helmet no she
doesn't really exist
she's sort of like uh
man ty teo's girlfriend
okay wait a minute you want to go go up
and around there go damn it
this is how my father walks
[Applause]
here i come
i'm a superhuman who has trouble
negotiating stairs
third floor
okay so now basically an artificial
gravity well has pulled uh the ship
infinity which came to rescue us on the
planet requiem and the didact who we've
awoken from his ancient slumber why is
everyone sleeping
we slept for four years and now there's
a die deck without an ancient slumber it
sounds like it's planet ambien that's
what it sounds like
people are just napping all the time
then they wake up and kill and then they
time for another slumber
we're gonna play co-op mode you're on
top okay
i wanna touch that here we go okay
now i'm just spinning around
you know what i'm panicking in battle
and just spinning in circles
all right you had trouble in the forest
so now we're going to get in a tank here
we go here we go there we go all right
so kind of go right into that oh yeah
you know what i'm doing better in the
tank than i did with just my own body
yeah
when i was growing up my parents had a
large station wagon a 1970 pontiac and
that's what i learned to drive on and
this handles a lot like a 1970 pontiac
look i'm lighting this guy up have some
death you want some death
have a death cookie you want a death
cookie with some
blow up milk you're the worst trash
talker i've ever heard you want some
flan made of you're dead
okay our tank got a little messed up the
good news is this is a rental
that's the good news we're just going to
turn this back in
to hertz and say i don't know this way
when i got it what are we moving on to
now you disobeyed orders and decided not
to hand over cortana so now you're going
rogue and you're gonna oh they wanted my
sexy girl yes and i didn't give her up
yes does she know that i didn't give her
up i think so i hope so that would be
money in the bank if you know what i
mean
come on chief
take a girl for a ride
oh my god
i've never licked a remote before
so now i thought we could move on to the
level where you're actually in i'm in
this is the level that i recorded the
voice for this is the level that you're
in yeah okay so that's us yeah that's me
and andy this is a pretty sweet union
we're in that's fantastic
stand near the crates but don't ever
move them
if anybody even looks at the crates
that's a violation that's great
don't you think rugs would warm this up
a little bit absolutely absolutely just
like literally i'm not talking
wall-to-wall but like five area rugs
gamers must hate this
but i'm talking about area rugs in their
sacred game
can i shoot myself
uh you can elbow yourself to death i
think something's up what i think
there's gonna be a war with an alien
they awoke from an ancient slave
i just
punched myself in the face i've always
wanted to do that andy's running away if
you want where's andy i want to hunt
andy down here where is there he's
running for me
and he's hard to get he's fast
he's wily
sleep tight richter
you know what it was more satisfying to
punch knock myself out that's my
self-loathing at work all right so how
would you rate halo 4. halo 4 i have to
say uh fantastic graphics good god uh
that woman is absolutely gorgeous i'm
very attracted to that woman
and uh almost to the point of it being
sad
how do i rate the game um let's say i'll
use noises if a
is very good
is very bad i'm going to give this a
summoner
that's my rating figure it out
[Applause]
[Music]